today Alzheimer's affects nearly 6
million Americans and that number is exp
expected to nearly triple in the next
few decades here to talk more about
brain health is Dr Yvonne Berry of
Valley Oaks Medical Group a contracted
provider for Optum Care Network the
sponsor of this segment uh doctor thank
you so much for being here June is
Alzheimer's Awareness Month also brain
health and I think it it there's
probably very few people that aren't
affected either directly or indirectly
by Alzheimer's or some form of dementia
it seems to be more common yes
Alzheimer's is probably the commonest
one it affects 30 to 40 percent of all
Americans probably 14 15 percent is from
cardiovascular dementias and then
there's something called alcohol induced
encephalopathy that will also affect
certain number of people over 65. yeah
and it's a little disconcerting to know
that that could be happening to a loved
one or to yourself how do you know the
difference between forgetfulness and and
growing older maybe a lesser form of
dementia and Alzheimer's so
forgetfulness oh we it happens to all of
us as we get older one of the things
that you and I will do we'll put a set
of glasses on our head we're looking for
them through the house all of a sudden
you see yourself in the mirror and you
go oh there they are someone with
dementia especially Alzheimer's will go
what is that on my head they won't be
able to recognize the object and there's
a natural tendency to try to cover that
up oh yes for sure and people will deny
it they will get depressed over it they
may hide that they're depressed and they
also get very aggressive they'll get
angry with their spouse they will yell
at their child for trying to make them
feel like there's something wrong with
them and one of the things that they're
really afraid of is having their freedom
taken sure their driver's license being
put into a nursing home you know losing
their ability to be independent and
that's early stages that's one of the
big things that we look for
understandable concerns so what can be
done let's start with people who have
been diagnosed with Alzheimer's there's
no cure per se there's no cure we can
slow it down there are certain
medications that we use that can slow it
down but we can't ever stop we can
decrease the progress of it certain
things you can do is definitely have
good nutrition stop smoking Don't drink
don't drink more than two drinks a week
of alcohol get out and do some exercise
but some of the more important things
are have a community have people you can
go out with make sure that you keep in
touch with your friends you take care of
your neighbor in some way so that you
have a sense of community that is a big
factor in it as well what about
preventative measures you hear things
like antiperspirants or other factors
could come into play is that true and
are there things that we can be doing to
keep our brain sharper maybe avoid
Alzheimer's
Alzheimer's is hard to avoid if you have
genetically predisposed to it but things
like additives in our Foods things like
you said like antiperspirants that may
have aluminum or other harmful products
in it keeping up with making sure that
you have the right type of vitamins like
B vitamins is really important in your
diet to keep up as well and getting out
to exercise every day it doesn't have to
be strenuous you have to have a gym
membership but go out and walk enjoy the
sunshine do a little meditation listen
to music especially classical music
where you have to kind of identify the
violin versus a trumpet those kind of
things are important do crossword
puzzles you know do Sudoku if you like
that exercise the body and the mind on
the mind yeah yes doctor thank you so
much doctor I appreciate you being here
today we want to thank Optum for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can call the number on
your screen or visit optumcare.com
forward slash Nevada we'll be right back